das verbot ist eine katastrophe genauso
wenn auch einzelne städte münchen da
haben die wirte mir erzählt 50 bis 90
umsatzrückgang in der hotellerie genauso
was meinen sie was unsere betriebe jetzt
am donnerstag freitag samstag erlebt
haben eine stornierungswelle
ohnegleichen und und die gäste sind auf
maximal verunsichert und frustriert will
kommt an dieser stelle für den schaden
auf wäre schön wenn die
ministerpräsidenten dazu auch eine
antwort geschrieben hätten oder auch die
datenschutzrechtlichen fragen bezüglich
des corona test ist ein persönliches
gesundheitszeugnis darf der hotel jeder
von der kopie machen also da sind ganz
viele fragen einfach im moment ungeklärt
und mit seinem aktionismus kriegen wir
keine akzeptanz ian meine branche hat
mehrheitlich super super mitgemacht wir
haben im august 50 millionen
übernachtungen in deutschland gehabt ich
kenne keinen einzigen infektionsfall das
rk ii hat zahlen veröffentlicht von ende
februar bis mitte juli schon ab saison
ja sind 55.000 cupid 19 fälle untersucht
worden da wurden nur 1,6 prozent der
fälle einem ausbruchsgeschehen in der
gastronomie und hotellerie bundesweit
zugeordnet das sind die mir letzten
bekannten zahl zu süß und ich finde wenn
jetzt hier solche maßnahmen und dann
noch in seiner geschwindigkeit und
koordiniert ergriffen werden wo viele
menschen sich hier auf den urlaub
gefreut haben im eigenen land jens spahn
hatte ja auch noch dazu aufgerufen ja
also da ist denn eine maximale
enttäuschung da viele ungeklärte
rechtsfragen also so kriegen wir keine
akzeptanz